ich bin der meinung es betreibt den
größten brainwash
gewissen teil von
shrek
das ist gut zur reportage harnik panik
jetzt reden die opfer dieser reportage
machen zeige dass in schweizer
psychiatrie sieht jahre nach wie vor
schwierig erzählt therapiert wird und
dass er tief schockiert sie ganz
willkommen da rinne unserem video unter
anderem da top kommentar vor dem
coburger danke dass ihr euch von all dem
negativen feedback zur ersten reportage
nicht habt stoppen lassen und den
betroffenen eine stimme gibt das muss
endlich aufhören und ihr habt den anfang
dazu gemacht danke für euren mut ich
auch an unangenehme themen hand zu wagen
und wichtig ist dass man ganz verliert
dann entzündet wo die verschwörungs
erzähle ich und aufklärungsarbeit
leisten und dass er da schon gefruchtet
sie peilt sap nämlich bin schockiert hat
heute zum ersten mal davon gehört das
was da abgeht muss sofort weiter
aufgeklärt und nachgearbeitet werden
weil ich was die pilots das machen wir
mit rat und die kevin zum beispiel seit
danke robin und ilona dass ihr etwas
gegen diese missstände in unserem
gesundheitssystem unternimmt und das
quattro schrieb super dass ihr die leute
selber sprechen lässt denen diese gewalt
der satellit panic angetan wurde aber
natürlich sind da unter dem video wieder
viele kritische kommentare wo sage doch
das kitz es geht der rituelle
satanistische missbrauch zum später
renato er schreibt das gehört vielleicht
zum spiel dazu es wird lächerlich
gemacht und jetzt soll mal jemand noch
versuchen das gegenteil zu beweisen
es gilt bis zum heutigen tag credit
suisse für das atheistische rituelle
missbrauch von vernetzter eliten oder im
untergrund macht und zum das vielleicht
auch moritz bringen haben wir der hugo
stamm hoffe der who gestorben ist zach
der experte sieht über die region und
wenn einer weiß ob es das gibt oder
nicht denn ich sehe es geht krey bewies
in der schweiz bewies das sonnige
aktuelle war also nicht sexuelle
übergriff im katholischen milieu
stadtkinder hat man kann nicht einfach
kind umbringen oder babys und
verschwinden
da ist alles
registriert und fordert er es gibt cafés
und wenn es sony die weltweiten mit
garantieren und wo züge bei oder vor
zurück weil uns steckt und wir
informationen
das haben nicht einhalte und ich selber
sehr viel erfahrungen diesbezüglich dass
sich
vermeintliche opfer von sexueller
satanischer rituale bei mir meldet und
ich hatte eine abfrage recherchieren und
sobald ich glaube ja wo hat der stadt
gefunden wenn nicht das gesicht christi
namen nennen wo deine täter und so eine
schnittmenge und die frau hätten
mögliche fragen gestellt zum
recherchieren mit den sofort auge der
satanische umkreist uhr wird ein
misstraut mir ja der glaube mir die
augen in decken sich wieder zusammen in
panische circa die frage mich in
hochgradig traumatisierte die mir sehr
leid aber das sind wir falsche
erinnerung wie schwierig das für sie
startet wird berichtet wenn wir mehr
reportage machen heißt es gerade schütze
damit missbrauchsopfer mit ernster ist
doch wichtig denn es stimmt es geht und
das bringt eine ganz blöde situation
ich verstehe das
abbruchreife von mir sagte sich ja mit
trikotnummer ja sagt opfer begleiten
unterstützen
also von daher sehr wohl auf die 700
vorbild für die heimfahrt also sechs
opfer und das für mich
selbstverständlich war ich also eine
kleine kammer zu mehr um die heimische
welle unterstützt aber nicht nötig da
kann ich auch nicht helfen und dann muss
man den hut so helfe dass man ihr seid
es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich aber
der therapeuten sind eigentlich sie
befreien für deine ängste und denke mir
strich die auch noch mit therapieren was
ich mir vorstelle ist dass man eine
drama stationen wo die therapeutin
täterkreise vor dem organisierter
messbuch was nicht geht dass sich doch
niemand von der anderen therapeut das
hat das alle denn glaubens konstrukt
noch
das ist das ist schon nicht der ganz
grosse rätsel in ihrer geschichte
ich meine die sind institutionen im
bunde war fachlich
hochqualifiziert sie und die müssen wir
eigentlich
dass uns in
hearings machen oder experten die die
müsste das auch schaffe die meisten mit
den mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter wo ag
satanischer rituale glaube dass sich
bislang setzte und die große
verantwortung und dort mit sind nicht
nur die therapeutin geherzt
mitverantwortete sondern die institution
wo sie drin schafft aber wir hören wir
jetzt nur dass mindestens im
professionellen umfeld
das also ich muss leider zu gestehen ich
bisher
desillusioniert also ich habe wieder auf
wie die gesundheitsbehörde und ich lauf
bei der krankenkasse auf wo
missbräuchliche therapie bezahlt und sie
wissen untersuchen sagt ganz neuen und
erfahrenen schutzhülle sich deine alten
ein system das sind sie blau oder rot
klima finger verbrennen dank dass man ja
gewinnen ich schlag ziel erfüllt und als
reaktion geht und da gibt es die
schlammschlachten es ist einfach so
denn wie ich - und man wohl nicht nur
hat man hat ja klar
strafrechtlich ist endlich gefallen aber
in grenzen paragraf oder handhaben von
einem prinzip auch so lange das nicht
entdeckt sich gegenseitig und nehmen und
wird sich finger verbrennen und die
schule angestoßen und damit alle
mitverantwortlich wenn sonne geht
missbrauch passiert
daniela beschrieb tja hier werden große
behandlungsfehler aufgezeigt das ist
schmerzhaft aber ein beweis gegen die
existenz von ritueller gewalt ist das
folgerichtig nicht
man muss also das gegenteil bewiesen
muss bewiesen dass es bis nicht gilt ja
genau das ist mir nicht vor juni also
zum beispiel
nadia schrieb nur weil es keine belege
gibt bedeutet es nicht dass es das nicht
gibt oder gala schreibt nur weil man
etwas nicht nachweisen kann heißt das
nicht dass es das nicht gibt deshalb
sollte man solche themen mit vorsicht
betrachten und nicht versuchen die
einzige wahrheit zu finden ich ziehe in
der heutigen zeit alles in betracht zu
dem thema da der frank urbaniok sich
noch mal größeren und erbringt
eigentlich klar auf den punkt das machen
alle verschwörungstheorien die sagen die
sagen die entziehen sich den belägen
indem sie sagen es ist gerade ein beleg
dass man nichts findet juror
funktioniert genauso man macht es immer
extremer immer verrückter immer gesagt
es ist ein kennzeichen dass man das
nicht belegen können wie perfekt die
arbeiter und da sind wir in dem
geschlossenen system drin weil das nicht
mehr an der realität überprüfbar ist
umso extremer die szenarien sind umso
eher die ihn so eine vorurteils struktur
reinlaufen von irgendwelchen mächten die
und was machen um so groß dass die
beweispflicht und nicht unser kleiner
ich setze mich vehement für opfer und
für weniger straftaten ein vehement aber
ich mache das auf allen seiten und sagen
nicht nur auf der seite und auf der
seite interessiert mich nicht sondern
menschen die falsch beschuldigt werden
und patienten die falsch therapiert
werden das sind auch opfer und es gibt
opfer von sexuellem missbrauch da sind
auch opfer und wir werden da wo opfer
sind da muss man die augen aufmachen
hingucken und das entsprechend auch
anprangern wenn es dazu mischten jede
kommentar steht aber immer wieder doch
mehr hausberge zum beispiel rick james r
schreibt einfach eppstein fragezeichen
zum dass kläger haben eine
kriminalpsychologin getroffen und zwar
nehmend ging es als lydia benecke sie
beschäftigt sich schon seit vielen
jahren mit der technik panik es gibt
doch ganz schlimm kindesmissbrauch es
gibt fritzl mit natascha kampusch es
gibt den fall absteigen wieso soll es
dann den satanistischen rituellen
missbrauch nicht geben es ist sehr
typisch das real existierende fälle in
denen es auch verurteilungen gibt
herangezogen werden und das dann gesagt
wird genau weil es solche fälle gibt
gebe es ja auch andererseits diese
elitäre netzwerke von tätern die aber
dann nie identifiziert werden nie
irgendwie verurteilt werden und hier
beginnt die verschwörungs erzählung dann
wird gesagt ja die werden aber nie
identifiziert und verurteilt weil die so
mächtig sein so im untergrund aber
gleichzeitig so elitär und dann ist
natürlich ein sich selbst erhaltendes
konstrukt man könne keine belege finden
weil ja diese geheimen möchte dafür
sorgen würden dass es keine belege gibt
und natürlich ist das ein typisches
merkmal einer verschwörung erzählung und
dann wird eben häufig so argumentiert
dass gesagt wird es ist ja nachgewiesen
dass es in religiösen gruppen sei es in
christlichen kirchen oder auch insekten
zu missbrauchsfällen kommt gar keine
frage da werden ja auch menschen
verurteilt das sind wieder taten die
natürlich belegbar sind und wo wir auch
wissen es gibt urteile und dann wird
gesagt ja wenn es die aber gibt wenn es
die insekten gibt die wir kennen wo
leute verurteilt sind und in
christlichen kirchen dann gibt es die ja
bestimmt auch in diesen und da sind wir
wieder gruppen die man aber nicht
identifizieren kann die so im untergrund
agieren und für die es ja nie
irgendwelche belege gebe und ich sag
dann immer nur weil es flugzeuge und
hubschrauber gibt ist das kein beleg
dafür dass uns außerirdische mit ufos
besuchen und das ist jetzt nicht
respektlos gemeint sondern damit billig
verdeutlichen dass wenn man reale
tatsachen vermischt mit einem nicht
nachgewiesenen konstrukt beziehungsweise
in diesem fall ein konstrukt das sogar
widerlegt ist dann verwirrt das
natürlich und das ist das problem auch
bei den begrifflichkeiten dass hier sehr
unterschiedliche themen in einen topf
geworfen werden das thema war bei uns in
eine klinik der schweiz bei euch in
deutschland ganz ehrlich ab hingeschaut
sie noch viel schlimmer aus in
deutschland sehen wir leider in den
letzten jahren eine zunahme dieses
phänomens das auch zunehmend auf
fortbildungsveranstaltungen das narrativ
der sätechnik panic als realität
verkauft wird und das ist da auch einige
unterstützer gibt die sehr gut vernetzt
sind und genau auch deswegen hoffe ich
sehr dass auch in deutschland endlich
sich kritisch auseinandergesetzt wird
damit um auch dort menschen davor zu
schützen eben opfer dieses verschwörungs
negativ zu werten was wir uns auch immer
wieder anhören müssen ist es vielen die
fakten und du hast dich ganz intensiv
damit auseinandergesetzt dass einen
langen vortrag auch auf youtubetm mal
angucken kann für alle die die jetzt die
fakten wollen wo finden sie die ja
dieser vortrag ist auf der youtube-seite
des deutsch amerikanischen institut
heidelberg der wurde 2020 hochgeladen
und heißt satanisch panisch wenn ihr
also lydia wenige japanisch spanisch bei
youtube ein gebt dann findet ihr den der
ist über anderthalb stunden lang da habe
ich sehr viele quellen da habe ich die
komplette geschichte der technik panic
aufgearbeitet und da werdet ihr also die
ganzen fakten dann auch in ruhe anhören
können und neue letzter kommentar vor
der china sie schreibt ich bin entsetzt
warum hilft da niemand was sind unsere
politiker haben die alle weg gesehen mir
sind ebenfalls entsetzt und das um die
location oder spitze vom eisberg mehr an
die äußere erste reportage eine zeige wo
überall die schlimme verschwörungs
erzähl ich suche jetzt mehr an screen es
lebt niemand so genau warum wir mehr an
dem thema dranbleiben studierte zwei
reportagen post haushalt sich dort um
dort finden die beide seiten
zusammen